اهلا بكم من جديد ازمه المنطاد الصيني
اثارت جدلا في الداخل الامريكي خاصه من
جهه الجمهوريين ما فتح المجله للتساؤل عن
تداعيات ذلك على الحزبين الجمهوري وخاصه
الديمقراطي رئيس لجنه القوات المسلحه
بمجلس النواب الامريكي النائب الجمهوري
مايك رودجرز عبر عن قلقه من قرار اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن بالسماحي لمنطاد الصين
بعبور الولايات المتحده واتهم الاداره
الامريكيه بانها كانت تامل في اخفاء فشل
الامن القومي هذا عن الكونجرس وعن الشعب
الامريكي واعتبر انه يجب على البيت الابيض
تقديم اجابات بشان الضرر الذي لحق بالامن
القومي من هذا القرار مؤكدا انه يجب على
الولايات المتحده ان تظهر قوتها لردع
الصين وان هذا الفشل مثال اخر كما قال على
ضعف اداره بايدن
ازمه المنطاد الصيني انتقاد جمهوري
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب دخل
على خط الازمه مطالبا باسقاط المنطاد فورا
مارجوري تايلور جرين عضو مجلس النواب طلبه
بايدن باسقاط منقاد التجسس على الفور
مارك جرين رئيس لجنه الامن الداخلي بمجلس
النواب قال في بيان ان لجنته ستستمر في
طلب الاجابات من اداره الرئيس غبيه
جمهوريه بمجلس نواب الامريكي تخطط لاطلاق
تحقيق في تعامل اداره بايدن مع المنطاد
الصينيه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
الدكتور غريب الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بك دكتور ومعنا من هولاندو توم حرب
رئيس التحالف الامريكيه الشرق الاوسط
الديمقراطيه اهلا بك استاذ حرب اهلا بكم
ان ابدا مع الاستاذ حرب طالما الانتقادات
جاءت من الجمهورين اكثر في الواقع استاذ
توم ولا نعلم لماذا امتدت في الواقع هذه
الازمه الى الداخل الامريكي يعني وكان
الجمهوريين التقطوا هذا الموضوع
اعتبروا بان هذا الموضوع قادر ان يخدمهم
لماذا تحملون الديمقراطيين مسؤوليه امن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانسحاب هذا
الموضوع على جزئيه اخرى سناتي عليها في
مقابلك تيك توك مثلا
[موسيقى]
يتم اختراق الاجواء الامريكيه
فكما بالاحرى ان يكون هنالك سلاح اقوى عند
الصينيين سيبعثونه الى الولايات المتحده
يعني هذه ليست بالسهوله وليست قضيه
جمهوريه ام ديمقراطيه هذا امن قومي
للولايات المتحده ويجب التحقيق به ولكن
ليس الاولويه
ولكن الحزب الجمهوري حمل الديمقراطيين حمل
اداره بايدن مسؤوليه عدم القدره على حمايه
الحدود الامريكيه دكتور ادمود هل تعتقد
بانه اداره بايدن تتحمل المسؤوليه
تحياتي لك وللاستاذ طعام بدون شك اولا ان
اداره الرئيس بايدن ترى في هذه في هذا
المنطاد الصيني ربما زائر غير مرغوب به
هذا اقل ما يمكن وصفه به وبالتالي لانه
ياتي في وقت حرج بالنسبه للاداره
وللعلاقه بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
فالرايسي يقوم بالقاء خطابه عن حاله
الاتحاد وهو الخطاب السنوي الذي يتواجد
فيه الى الامه ككل وهو ايضا في الوقت الذي
نرى فيه المزيد من التحقيقات سنرى تحقيقات
من قبل الجمهوريين حول دوره حول الوثائق
حول دور ابنه حول علاقه ابنه بالصين علاقه
ابنه باوكرانيا دوره هو هل كان له دور
في نفس الوقت الذي تاتي كل هذه التحديات
جاء هذا المنطاد الصيني ليضع ضغوط اضافيه
كبيره على على الاداره لانه من ناحيه
الرئيس واجه وبداها كما ذكرتي
كانت هناك انتقادات كثيره من قبل
الجمهوريين الذين قالوا بان الرئيس تلكا
في اتخاذ القرار في التحرك ضد هذا هذا
المنطاد وبالتالي فهذا يثير اسئله حول
قدرته وكل هذا ياتي ايضا في الوقت الذي
يرغب فيه الرئيس في ترشيح نفسه
بظلالها على اولا موقع رئيس بايدن
الانتخابات القادمه واعتبر الجمهوريون بان
هذا ملف اخر يضاف الى ملفات اخرى للهجوم
على بايدن ولكن استاذه حضرتك عاده تكون
معنا وتدافع على وجهه النظر الجمهوريه
ولكن هذه المره تحدثت ان هذا الموضوع يخص
الجمهوريين كما الديمقراطين هل نفهم بان
هذا الموضوع قد يوحد الصف الامريكي ام ان
للجمهوريين حسابات اخرى
يعني انا هذا الموضوع سيوحد الجمهوريين
لانه الديمقراطيين ويجب ان يوح
دهم في مشاكل داخليه تفرق بين النظريات
ولكن المشاكل الخارجيه والامن القومي ليس
فيه اي تلاعب يعني ان كان بالانسحاب من
افغانستان اما الحرب باوكرانيا اما الوضع
بين الصين وتايوان كل هذه المشاكل يعني
هذه مشاكل قوميه تؤثر على القوميه الوطنيه
الامريكيه صحيح ولكن بمعنى ولكن استاذ توم
بمعنى يعني هذا الملف لن يستعمل ضد بايدن
لن يستعمل ضد الحزب الديمقراطي مثلا
هنالك
عده قضايا وعده مشاكل مع هذه الاداره بما
يختص العلاقه مع الصين وعنتر بايدن واخوه
للرئيس بايدن وكل هذه الملفات ستراكم هذه
الملفات سيكون لها تحقيق في الكونغرس
الامريكي وهذا كذلك الامر سيكون جزء يضاف
الى التحقيق الذي ستبداه الجمهوريون في
الاسابيع المقبله دكتور دماغ هذا الموضوع
انسحب حتى على استعمال تيك توك من عدمه
تمكين تيك توك من العمل في داخل الامريكي
من عدمه هل تعتقد بان الموضوع قد تنجر عنه
تداعيات اخرى او نتائج اخرى يتخذها
الكونجرس الامريكي
بدون شك اولا هناك فعلا خلافات
جمهوريين هم اجمالا اكثر تشددا تجاه الصين
ممن من الديمقراطيين الديمقراطيين اكثر
تشددا تجاه روسيا في نفس الوقت بدانا نرى
تباينات في بعض المواقف الامريكيه وخلافات
في داخل المؤسس مثلا راينا مركز ابحاثران
وهو من اهم مراكز الابحاث الامريكيه وهو
قريب جدا من وزاره الدفاع بدا يتحدث عن
ضروره البحث عن شبل دبلوماسيه وانهاء
النزاع في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي واستبعد ايضا عوده
الدراسه التي قدمت استبعدت اعاده شبه
جزيره القرم الى اوكرانيا وحتى المناطق في
شرق اوكرانيا وبالتالي فان هذه فعلا ستظهر
ايضا الخلافات بين الجمهوريين وبين
الديمقراطيين حول هذا الموضوع راينا بعض
الشخصيات الديمقراط قالت انه كان يجب من
بينهم ادم شيف الذي كان رئيسا للجنه
القوات المسلحه في السابق الذي قال بانه
يجب ان كان يجب على ان يذهب الى الصين
ويناقش الموضوع ويطرحه مع الصينيين
بالتالي اعتقد انه
التوترات ستزداد بين البلدين لعده اسباب
وليس فقط بسبب هذا المنطاد سيضيف اعباء
جديده ولكن هناك الان محاولات امريكيه
للحصول على قواعد في الفلبين هناك تعاون
مع اليابان ومع كوريا الجنوبيه لتعزيز
القدرات العسكريه وذلك بهدف مواجهه تايوان
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي هناك بانه قد
يزور ايضا وهو جمهوري كما نعلم جميعا يريد
الذهاب الى تايوان هذا سيزيد من التوترات
هناك موضوع فيكتراك تنفع ملايين التيك توك
سيتم ايقافه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه باختصار تعتقد
فعلا هذا اعتقد انه الان اصبح اكثر سهوله
ولكن تدفع كانت قد دفعت ملايين دولارات
للقوى العظمه في
الولايات لتساعدها على البقاء وبالتالي
هناك نقاش او هذا الموضوع مستمر ولكن هذه
القضيه ستزيد من التعقيدات وكذلك موضوع
العقوبات التي فرضت على شركات مثل هواوي
مثلا او شركات اخرى من موضوع الرقائق
والضغط على دول اخرى لكي تشتري الرقائق من
الصين
استاذ توم منذ قليل قلت حضرتك بان او كانت
لك انتقادات على التعامل مع هذا المنطاد
منطاد التجسس كما سمي ولكن هل تعتقد بان
لون الموضوع كان في يد الجمهوريه لكان
القرار
يعني اسهل او ربما في وقت اوجز في وقت اقل
ام ان الموضوع لا يتعلق بالاحزاب وانما
يتعلق بتقنيات لا تملكها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للرصد وكذلك
طريقه اسقاطه
يعني اولا من المضحك انه نكون ولايات
متحده وما عندش
مراقبه امكانيه مراقبه لمنطاد يدخل
الاجواء الامريكيه وانا اكيد لو كان مثلا
اداره الرئيس السابق ترامب هي بالحكم كانت
ما خلته حتى يوصل على السواحل في في ولايه
الاسكا ولكن
قالت بانه تم رصده قبل سبعه ايام يعني
تقريبا منذ دخوله ولكن لم يرد يعني نشر
ذلك حب يخليوه الموضوع شويه
سر ولكن كشف الموضوع في النهايه
صحيح
ولايات بالنتيجه ولكن لازم نحن نعرفه
عندما باداره
2020 عندما عرفوا وعلموا بالتنصت
بالقنصليه الصينيه في تكساس سكروها
اقفلوها مباشره يعني ما فيش تلاعب بالامن
القومي الامريكي وانا بتصور هذه الاداره
يعني فاتحه المجال المجال على الحدود
المكسيكيه المجال في كل مكان يعني الشعب
الامريكي صار مثل مخدر على كل اسبوع ماذا
سيسمع مفاجات من هذا وطريقه الاسقاط
استوقفت البعض لما اسقطتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بطائره
اثنين وعشرين اف 22 يعني شباحيه من الجيل
الخامس هذا ربما يفتح ملف رابع ولكن الوقت
انتهى من حلقه اليوم شكرا جزيلا لكما
دكتور ادمو غريبه الاستاذ العلاقه الدوليه
وتوم حرب رئيس تحالف الامريكي الشرق
الاوسط للديمقراطيه ولنقاش دائما بقي
مشاهدينا السلام عليكم